so
maybe you can say how tom cryer works
because it's like how
what's your vision you're now partnering
with with wolfram wolfe from alpha
and in sort of exploring this
partnership of
data and the blockchain
what's your vision for possible
distributed version of war from alpha
well you know the first step is just say
can we use this as a feed and they can
be what bloomberg is to the financial
markets
you know so you have a terminal and you
have something and there's always a
value of at least offering choice
and so it's not like we're anti-chain
link or we're picking winners and losers
it's an open protocol it's an open
system so if we're
successful chain link will migrate or it
will at least support us
because they like money you know they
like users they like liquidity
it's a disservice to their community not
to support a potential customer set
but you know you're gonna have a
spectrum from the desire to do
a completely decentralized aggregation
curation injection and veracity
attestation
to a completely centralized vertically
integrated set
you need to be able to have that whole
spectrum and offer that to the smart
contract
developer to decide you know what is
what makes sense by the way
a lot of cases they're going to be their
own oracle so for example the world of
warcraft
example that i gave well you know it's a
completely centralized thing it's a
video game run by a single company
i there's no sense in saying that we're
somehow going to decentralize that what
they're just trying to do is extend
their currency
or nfts or whatever into new
marketplaces
so the minting of that is controlled by
a single entity and the world state of
that you had just have to trust blizzard
to inject that into the system
you could try to imagine some sort of
like you know sentinel
group of people within the game who keep
blizzard honest
but it's completely unnecessary because
they can change the rules of the system
arbitrarily
so in that case you're optimizing around
efficiency and cost reduction so you'd
want a single feed that gets
injected into the system from them if
you look at a stable coin that's
algorithmic
and it's basing its value on the
aggregation of many different exchanges
that's the polar opposite example
because there you're saying okay what's
the price of my asset relative to some
basket
but how do i know that the price fees
i'm looking at are accurate
you have to look at binance and bittrex
and all these other things or maybe
there's conventional forex exchanges or
something like that
okay well how do you weight that and how
do you clip
outliers and you know these types of
things that's a completely different
conversation and there's a lot more
mechanics you have to put in for that
bundling and attestation of the veracity
of the data feed
and what happens if you get it wrong
your stable coin gets mispriced
and everything goes to hell and you know
the markets will eventually correct it
for arbitrage seeking behavior but
anything that was built on that will
fail
in the in the short term so oracle's
really just a game of
you know you have to build a
standardized interfaces and make it as
easy as possible for people to do that
and then let people choose how they want
to inject data and
what level of assurance do they need
behind that and the question is how much
do you leave to the user versus how much
does the protocol take care of
for you and it's it's a difficult design
question for our part you know we love
working with steve and wolf ram and
they're they're a great company and they
really have some bright people there
and we know on the data set they're
second to none because not only they
have it it's computable you can do all
kinds of things and manipulate with a
very
rich query language so that's a great
thing and we want to make sure that
that's accessible
to developers and cardano but remember
they're like bloomberg it's a
centralized
speed in that respect so if you want to
build a chain like s
competitor you know there's other
protocols you could do for that
now you asked about town crier and that
was that was an attempt to kind of
like sweep the oceans with the net you
know get some
get the data through a decentralized way
i and that was just saying hey let's use
trusted hardware to go read law
all kinds of websites and other things
and because there's trusted hardware the
scraping
is non-biased you know if you find
something inconvenient to whatever
the person who's scraping is it trusted
heart will still do it and it can't be
changed you'd have to manipulate sgx to
do that
uh so that's great but you still run on
the problem of how do you
wire that together the underlying
websites still don't have any notion of
veracity or
reputation behind them and then you also
have the issue of storage
where the hell do you put all of it yeah
if you have exabytes of data
what's the incentive for that that's the
dream of the semantic web
i still think is a fascinating idea i
had to basically convert the internet
into a court like um
a knowledge base that you can you can
query you can integrate the same way you
did with wolfram alpha but
much bigger right but that that means
basically
revolutionizing the way we put the
internet together
which i i think these ideas of off-chain
data
will uh will motivate people because
there's a lot of money to be made
and creating finally there's money to be
made with a semantic web
you